what's up guys Jubilee team at
Disneyland thank you so much for
watching we love you guys so much we're
about to go down this hill but in the
meanwhile enjoy the episode alcohol guys
just tell us we brought together seven
teenagers I'm a teenager I'm a teenager
I am a teenager I am a teenager I'm a
teenager I am a teenager I'm a teenager
one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the lier survives they win the entire
prize
I already guys all in college no I'm not
right where do you go
passing City College where'd you go I
don't quite a college what are you doing
nothing
a lot of people expect like eighteen
year old to go to college and move out I
didn't think it's very important to
understand that there's still people
that are like my age or even older to
still live with their parents how about
music I like
jouji i own a grande I like the choice
brother I felt like I don't know she was
trying a little bit too hard she was
wearing heels I was like you are 26 I
just kind of went off of like my gut
feeling get them all I think I was voted
out because the way I present myself and
the way I look I look very mature and
older really quick to any of you guys
vote for Hillary Clinton in the last
lecture I didn't know I wasn't old I was
16 yeah I have a question what do you
guys like to do on your free time I
skateboard
I play the switch with my friend yeah I
play like video game yeah I do every
YouTube channels do with my mom actually
so that's really fun I just ran strict
aureus on the phone
olá boys no I like the size take another
oh my god you guys got YouTube what you
do are you
okay like David or base is cool okay
like who do you watch on YouTube oh like
Miranda seeing some bunch oh oh when did
you guys promote from middle school 2014
[Applause]
us ha and then he had slippers SIA and
then so I was like who you must be tired
of being places I voted for him just cuz
he didn't speak a lot well I'm obviously
not an adult I don't know why you guys
don't think that but I like a lot of
things young kids like like one
direction although out together anymore
they're really great um what a kid shows
yeah I'm still a teenager my rooms messy
as hell my mom yells at me every day I
spend my time talking to my girlfriend
and playing video games which one's more
important I don't know I'm still a
teenager I need to figure that one out
[Music]
I thought I make it to the end actually
I don't know why maybe because I think I
look younger but I don't know like talk
about what's hard about being a teenager
so for me it's like not having money I
think if you're too loud you're
compensating for something
so Bianca was definitely talkative like
so at the stage where we're kind of
adults but we and we're like still
making minimum wage yeah yeah I don't
know I guess that's what kind of hard
about my source of money is yeah it's
embarrassing but yeah I mean that's okay
I have a scholarship fund about Bill
Gates so thank you you had to climb from
don't say that I think because my
savings is under 200 and then I had to
learn that five times and then yeah
that's why I got I don't have a credit
card right now at the moment Oh quote
your favorite favorite vine oh my gosh
oh my god I know that one he's after
chicken oh oh okay
the one we're like the guys in the
grocery store and then somebody throw
something at me he's like be well when'd
you get Twitter are you active do you
owe your Senators since you're from
California
I see something white Andrew yang and
that someone's like don't vote for him
okay for president yeah but do you know
who your senator is wait are you
wondering I know my stance yeah
[Music]
you're cool man he was like the easy
person to vote oh I thought everybody
else was gonna vote him out so I just
did you know what it is I do like do it
I'll do it with oh it's gonna be on the
internet you you got it this okay that's
a new thing that's like classic let's go
up your brother doesn't think I can do
this but like that's it okay popular
rapper when you were in like elementary
school I listened to Sean Kingston yes I
[Music]
didn't want to talk that much but I also
I thought that sometimes people were
talking too much about the wrong things
that wouldn't lead us to figuring out
who the mole was so I just wanted to
change the subject which okay probably
got me voted out but whatever I guess
I trusted him I'm 18 years of age a lot
of the TV shows they mentioned were part
of my childhood as well I just shifted
the timeline she was not on my radar at
all just the answer she was giving like
it just seemed like they flowed
perfectly it was funny I voted for
Brennan three times right he's giving me
a ride home so that's cool I thought a
lot of people weigh them all actually no
I would have never guessed it was Casey
for sure yeah she was really good
don't trust anybody out here you know I
can't trust nobody I can't trust you you
look are you a teenager really I can't
trust you thanks for watching I really
appreciate did your same slides okay
that's fine anyway Adrian ruined it but
thanks for watching bye alright let's do
another one